NO WORD IF THERE ARE SIGNS OF
VIOLENCE.
PROSECUTORS HAVE LAUNCHED AN
INVESTIGATION LOCALLY.
>> Trace: THE SENATE KICK
STARTING ITS LAME DUCK SESSION
WITH A LONG TO DO LIST.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL WANTS TO PASS MORE
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF AND A NEW
PACKAGE OF SPENDING BILLS
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
CHAD PERGRAM LIVE ON CAPITOL
HILL.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT IN THE WEEKS
AHEAD?
>> SOMETIMES IT’S EASIER TO GET
THINGS DONE DURING A LAME DUCK
CONGRESS.
SOMETIMES IT’S HARDER.
MITCH MCCONNELL MADE NO BONES
ABOUT IT HE WANTS TO DO ANOTHER
CORONAVIRUS BILL.
HE IS IN THE DRIVER’S SEAT
RIGHT NOW.
HE MAY PREFER TO GET SOMETHING
DONE UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION RATHER THAN WAIT
TO JANUARY.
ONE SENATOR WANTING A SMALLER
BILL IS MITT ROMNEY OF UTAH.
>> CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPLES ARE
STILL ON THE ASCENDENCE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AMERICAN DOESN’T WANT TO SIGN
UP FOR THE GREEN NEW DEAL OR
GETTING RID OF COAL, OIL, GAS,
OR MEDICARE FOR ALL.
>> HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
HAS TAKEN THE LEAD IN
CORONAVIRUS TALKS.
SHE NEGOTIATED ON A DAILY BASIS
WITH THE SECRETARY OF TREASURY
ON A LARGER 2.2 TRILLION BILL.
MCCONNELL WANTS SOMETHING
MORTAR GETED ESPECIALLY HAVE A
GOOD JOBS FIGURE FRIDAY.
WITH DEMOCRATIC LOSSES IN THE
HOUSE THERE ARE QUESTIONS AS TO
WHETHER PELOSI WOULD TAKE A
SMALLER DEAL.
>> NO, NO, IT DOESN’T APPEAL TO
ME AT ALL.
THEY STILL HAVE NOT AGREED TO
CRUSH THE VIRUS.
IF YOU DON’T CRUSH THE VIRUS
WE’RE STILL GOING TO HAVE TO BE
DEALING WITH THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE VIRUS.
>> HERE IS WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO.
THEY HAVE TO FUND THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE DEADLINE IS DECEMBER 11th.
THEY ALSO HAVE TO WRESTLE WITH
THE DEBT CEILING RAISING IT OR
SUSPENDING IT AND THEY ALSO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION BILL.
TRACE.
>> Trace: CURIOUS, CHAD.
A LOT OF BUZZ ON CAPITOL HILL
ABOUT THE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN JOE BIDEN AND MITCH
MCCONNELL.
>> YEAH, THEY ACTUALLY WERE
PRETTY GOOD FRIENDS.
THERE WAS A VERY STRIKING
MOMENT IN LATE DECEMBER 2016
WHERE MITCH MCCONNELL RENAMED
PART OF THE 21st CENTURY CURES
ACT AFTER BEAU BIDEN.
WE HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN.
BEAU SUCCUMBED TO CANCER.
THERE IS A CORDIAL RELATIONSHIP.
DID MCCONNELL HAVE ANY OUTREACH
TO THE BIDEN TRANSITION TEAM
AND THEY DON’T HAVE ANYTHING